this is us they're they're casting for a
new show you have no idea
whether or not this show is gonna be
ahead no idea how do you hear about the
audition for the cause you had to
audition for this oh yeah
were you insulted that you had
auditioned you had done quite a bit of
work
no way i wasn't insulted i mean i
audition
we all still audition unless you're at
meryl streep like that's the
the is that part of being an actor i'll
bet you now you wouldn't have to
audition
yeah i do i still do you do you'll go on
and meet with people and absolutely do
you like auditioning
it's like it's a certain skill set
you're walking into a
an uncomfortable situation with people
you don't know
you're reading not with another actor
it's usually a casting director so
and they put no energy no energy into it
so it's so much more nerve-wracking then
so you had done an animated movie right
you you had
done tangled which dan fogelman who
created this is us had written
this guy uh dan fogerman's a genius i
mean the way he puts together these
scripts is really inventive
yeah so he has a script he worked with
you on this animated thing and
does he say to you hey i got a new show
once you come in and audition i mean
it's like six years apart oh it is so he
wasn't thinking of you no way
um i had just moved agencies
and we had all talked about the fact
that like moving forward
maybe let's let's not focus on
traditional pilot season
which i had just gone through for like
four years and nothing had come of it
let's focus on like the amazons and the
netflix and hulu's of the world that are
sort of casting all year round
so i just signed with this new agent we
decided let's not look at like network
pilot season and then two weeks later i
get the script for the untitled dan
fogelman project and it's in like in
october and it's a network show
it was for nbc it said and it was off
cycle because pilot season's usually
from january to like
april and i was like what the [ __ ] is
this like did we not just talk about the
fact that like we weren't gonna focus on
network tv like nbc
right you tried all that uh yeah and i
was like i don't wanna get my hopes up
again
but i read the script sort of
reluctantly and of course
my jaw's on the floor the script knocked
you out script knocked me out did you
get the character right away did you
understand that you'd have to play four
different
characters in other words you're playing
an old pilot no you have to play an old
woman yeah
you have to play a uh young woman who's
dating kind of thing
then you got to play a young married
woman and pregnant and all that stuff
i mean it's a very incredible ritual
absolutely but none of that's on the
page in the pilot like the first episode
you're trying to understand how the show
works and who all these
people are and how these stories are
related and
i'm just existing as like this woman
who's pregnant with triplets who has
the babies and there's a complication i
lose one of the kids and
that's sort of all you know from the
first episode so so you really wanted
this
i wanted it and i remember reading it
and thinking like wow okay cool like i
don't really know who this woman is or
where the story goes from here there's
the the doors are open to like a
multitude of possibilities
how many actresses auditioned for that i
don't know
but i went in at the very beginning i
remember i was one of the first people
that read for it because the feedback
was they liked you
but now they're going to go to new york
and they're going to read more girls
here in l.a
so you probably won't hear for like a
month or maybe six weeks wouldn't it be
nice to hear hey you did a great
audition
you're it of course yeah but they go and
and that stuff but they were like
you're in early we still have all the we
want to go to other cities and read
people and
do the whole thing so i was like all
right and do you train yourself to
not keep an eye on what's going on with
that because if you did you'd go insane
insane if you're sitting by the phone
wanting that roll it's crazy
totally when you go on an audition uh
for for this is us
are you uh put with uh milo well
so six weeks later i get a call like
okay it's you
and like two other girls oh my god and
there's gonna be so it's like three
girls three guys and everyone's gonna
come in and do a chemistry read so the
chemistry a chemistry right but you
gotta say
you gotta see so they i remember hearing
that milo was the guy to beat they love
this guy milo ventamilia
and like he's the front runner and i was
like okay i've heard of him i know i
vaguely know who he is yeah what had he
been in he did a couple of things kill
more girls and that show heroes like
he's done
tv yeah yeah so i go into this chemistry
read well
first because there's not a ton
happening in that first episode
they dan wrote this monologue that ended
up appearing in the second episode where
i basically
confront my husband eight years later
about him drinking too much
and it has to stop because they've got
to give you something to do they have to
give well they have to sort of see like
can she do this other thing that the
show is really going to be based around
right so i i did that monologue and then
they brought me in to read with milo
and you know you don't know the person
you shake hands and you're like hi
you're gonna be my husband now like
nuzzle into my neck and let's pretend to
be in love and about to be birthing
three children
that's why i think it's so hard to marry
an actor or an actress because you have
that ability to completely
lock in with someone else that's right
yeah i mean sometimes it's easier than
others like him and i
it was instant it was easy it was
effortless it was like right there
something with him i did i was like oh
this is this is great
whereas sometimes you don't feel that
right yeah sometimes you're like
sometimes you're grossed out you're like
oh how am i gonna do like
like if the person's an [ __ ] sure
you're like how am i gonna find
some way to make them attractive in my
brain and what do you do you just find
something like it like you find
something
like hey i'm looking at his hair it's
nice i can love his